welcome to hannity and tonight as we
speak fake news outlets all over the
country
they are drooling over kamala harris
they are singing her praises they are
writing what are cringe-worthy fluff
pieces
to of course please their far left
editors but while they lie to your face
again we will bring you the truth we
will as usual do the job the state-run
propaganda hate trump media mob cult
refuses to do buckle up because tonight
we are vetting
kamala harris and it continues in just
moments
we will call out her phony praise of joe
biden wow amazing at what a day can do
and it can change everything
we'll also show you her very most
radical
socialist positions from police to
fracking
the consumption of red meat and even the
elimination of straws
and all private health care plans that
would be outlawed
and her support of gun bans by executive
fiat
also vice president mike pence will
weigh in straight ahead
but we start in wilmington delaware
where biden somehow managed to travel
a few miles away from his basement
bunker to introduce his new running mate
after what a three-hour delay an
extremely long meandering speech
delivered with the help of his trusty
teleprompter
in an almost empty gymnasium joe biden
finally made it official
and during the joint event didn't take
questions after trashing president trump
predictably
of course both biden and harris heaped
scripted praise all over each other
it was so fake so blatantly pony that
you couldn't help but kind of cringe
when you know the truth
it was only a few months ago that kamala
harris was
heavily suggesting that joe biden was a
racist and a sexist
oh amazing how things change in election
years isn't it
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me his empathy
his compassion his sense of duty
to care for others is why i am so proud
to be on this ticket it's a
mischaracterization my position across
the board i did not praise
racist kamala knows how to govern she
knows how to make the hard calls
she's ready to do this job on day one
praising and coddling
individuals who made it their life works
and built their reputation
off of segregation of the races in the
united states
that's a problem his empathy his
compassion
his sense of duty to care for others
is why i am so proud to be on this
ticket
well the kamala harris back then was
right because joe biden praised the guy
that actually filibustered the civil
rights act and opposed the voting rights
act that historic both historic
legislation
and work with the former klansmen on the
issue of stopping the integration of
schools and saying he didn't want his
kids going to school in a quote racial
jungle
so why would joe biden pick a running
mate who all but pretty much called him
racist over
and over again why would he pick someone
who said i believe
biden's sexual misconduct accusers well
the answer is simple senator harris
is a favorite of the radical far left
establishment
new york toilet paper times though they
called her a pragmatic
moderate uh no way shape or form that's
just another outright lie by the new
york times
2019 she had the most liberal voting
record of any other u.s
senator she was actually to the left of
bolshevik bernie sanders
she was the co-sponsor of that insane
green new deal
and maybe they're just trying to cover
up this crazy socialist agenda
by giving congresswoman ocasio-cortez a
whopping 60 seconds we found out tonight
to speak at the democratic convention
unfortunately for kamala harris that she
is now on tape promising to ban
all fracking pennsylvania are you paying
attention
on day one in office take a look
will you commit to implementing a
federal ban on fracking your first day
in office
adding the united states the list of
countries who have banned this
devastating practice there's no question
i'm in favor of banning fracking
so yeah all right with that one radical
move that would cost a half a million
high-paying jobs in pennsylvania yeah
hundred thousand plus jobs in ohio
millions of other jobs across the
country
it would send the price of oil and gas
the lifeblood of our economy through the
roof
and there's a lot more as part of a
radical socialist agenda
harris would even ban plastic straws and
limit
your consumption of red meat i just love
when the government is there to tell me
how to live
and if you like your doctor if you like
your health insurance plan
well you're going to want to listen very
closely to this next
insane radical socialist clip take a
look
i believe the solution and i'm and i'm
actually feel very strongly about this
is that we need to have medicare for all
that's just the bottom line i believe it
will totally eliminate private insurance
um so for people out there who like
their insurance
they don't get to keep it well listen
the idea is that everyone gets access to
medical care who of us have
has not had that situation where you've
got to wait for approval and the doctor
says well
i don't know if your insurance company
is going to cover this let's eliminate
all of that let's move on
eliminate it move on uh wow then you're
stuck with obamacare
how do those promises work out now if
harris gets away over 200 million
americans could
would have their health insurance
stripped away no choice no option i
thought liberals were pro-choice
apparently not on this issue
and of course your taxes they will go
through the roof she's already plotting
major tax hikes so let's keep track of
this
minor part of her radical agenda senator
harris would confiscate your private
health insurance
your income yep even says my executive
fiat
i'm going to take away some of your guns
your plastic straws your red meat and
that list goes on
she wants government to completely
dictate every aspect of your life
that's because like many other radical
socialists left well
senator harris believes that the
american people actually says it about
one particular voting bloc and
demographic or just stupid
well you don't believe me let's go to
the videotape
what else do we know about this
population 18-24
they are stupid
that is why we put them in dormitories
and they have a resident assistant
they make really bad decisions
well we just lock them all up till
they're 25. now if you watch the other
so-called news networks or read almost
any paper in the country
you will never get the truth about
senator harris you will never see these
clips you will never hear about her
radical positions and a radical record
they will lie to you day in and day out
for the next 83 days
and they will continue to push the line
that she is a pragmatic
moderate at this point the mob the media
has
absolutely zero self-respect and they
don't concern
concern themselves with anything that
recognizes truth
they are now hardcore status partisan
democrats
that will say and do anything to beat
donald trump
it's a cult of hatred a psychosis kind
of hard to explain actually
just take a look at their vetting of
kamala harris take a look
just being told we have a pick and it's
kamala harris
of california just told in my ear
at this second for the record those
applause were
from claire mccaskill i think that
kamala harris adds
a layer of energy to the biden campaign
people wanted to be around her there was
a charisma a fascination for lack of a
better word anderson
a bit of celebrity surrounding kamala
harris joe biden
could have chosen someone else but he
couldn't have chose anyone better
she is clearly a great campaigner but
she's also
good at governing democrats have thought
since she stepped onto the stage that
she had an incredibly
bright future i think if you think about
kamal harris she herself
a fighter right she's an energetic
campaigner
a women's vote younger people's vote
all of this brings enormous energy
one pretty much anybody would have more
energy than well the ever forgetful joe
seems like he needs a nap very often and
she only got two percent
or less the coverage was so bad so
abusively biased one of these fake
journalists and lunatic at fake news cnn
complained
that we were throwing everything but the
kitchen sink
at kamala harris that's actually called
vetting the candidate
fake news cnn might want to try it out
sometime on a
democratic candidate just the
candidate's record
just the exact things which they have
said in the positions they've taken
with the accompanying proof the video
and audio tapes
especially now all of the obvious
concerns about biden's frankly
mental alertness acuity for fitness for
office is strength and stamina
now get this the media raised those
questions about 71 year old john mccain
and his
age in 2008 they raised questions about
73 year old ronald reagan
during his re-election bid in 1984.
by the way for the record biden would be
older on
his first day of office than reagan was
on his last day of office
take a look i am not going to exploit
for political purposes my opponent's
youth and inexperience checkmate ronald
reagan 149 states now all of a sudden
the mob
and the media they don't dare ask a
question about 77-year-old biden's
mental acuity
i'm not a doctor but he looks kind of
fragile tired
weak to me and these uh well constant
embarrassments
they're beginning to raise a lot of
serious questions and people in the
country are talking about it whether the
mob wants to or cover it up or not
the confusion the bouts of anger are you
a junkie
you get tested for cocaine come on man
almost no one outside of this network
seems even willing to seriously broach
the subject
we will do our job in fact they're
actively trying to
cover up his apparent issues over there
at state-run conspiracy television msdnc
well they seemingly actually cropped out
what appeared to be a written script
of biden you know and having a casual
video conversation with
kamala harris and by the way you can
actually see biden in that picture
he's holding the phone upside down
and ultimately the biden campaign is
hoping that kamala harris will bring a
much needed boost of energy
charisma alertness that biden clearly
lacks
those are fundamentals i think for the
hardest job in the world
and there's one problem with that theory
kamala well she doesn't connect with
voters
her presidential bid was a massive
failure a flop
she dropped out in december before any
primary or
any caucus she was polling at a meager
two percent or less
especially after tulsi gabbard's
takedown even in her home state of
california she was polling in single
digits they know her best
but fear not the media mob the cult that
they are that hates trump 24
7 all they'll do and say anything and
everything they can to
help lift her up just take a look at
today's front page
new york toilet paper times it's
worthless basically as
good as toilet paper compared to their
coverage in 2016
of vice president pence donald trump's
choice for a running mate
as we've said many times on this show
back from 2007
forward journalism is dead it is gone it
is buried